derrière ces portes se cache le paradis
des consommateurs de bière un bar dédié
en grande partie à la boisson alcoolisée
s'est ouvert le 16 janvier dernier dans
le centre-ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
le lieu est géré par ludovic constantin
amateurs de cet alcool depuis ses 18 ans
c'est vraiment le domaine que je connais
le mieux que je peux expliquer aux
clients même si je propose du vin et des
alcools
c'est vraiment ce que je préfère tout
simplement le bar propose plus de 150
références de bière et notamment des
spécialités françaises deux premiers
meubles sont que des bières locales
vraiment d'île de france et après les
deux autres sont des bières aussi de
france 2 partout par exemple ici c'est
des bières du nord
ici des bières normande est ici des
bières de haute-savoie la bière ne coule
pas encore à flot mais la recette
commence à payer chaque jour le barreau
soit une quinzaine de clients dans ses
80 mètres carrés
pas sympa c'est parfois que je viens et
ouais sympa l'ambiance est agréable
j'aime bien la bière maintenant je vis
dans le nord à lille donc généré vierge
en bois c'est vraiment écolo franchement
c'est super d'avoir un bar à bières dont
voisins
c'est pas grand chose à part ça que ça
palabre est bonne n'est ce pas trop cher
il vous faudra débourser en moyenne 2
euros 80 pour un demi-litre et 5 euros
pour une bouteille de 33 centilitres et
si les clients ne veulent pas rester
accoudé au comptoir ils peuvent
également acheter des bières à emporter